[Applause]
live from the headquarters of ramsy
solutions it's the ramsy show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships the phone number here is
88255 225 Jade washaw Ramsey personality
bestselling author is my co-host we're
glad to have you with us today Chase is
going to start this day off in h
Jacksonville Florida hi Chase how are
you hey I'm good Dave how are you guys
better than I deserve what's
up um I me and my wife uh recently
started doing your baby steps here on
New Year's um I got your book The Total
Money Makeover um we added everything up
and mortgage included we have like
45,000 in debt currently uh because we
recently bought a house um we make like
146k salary combined and I'm just
wondering if that seems doable normal
like taking the normal path or do you
think we have to do something
drastic well how much of the debt is
your
mortgage about
329 okay um yeah so the way we teach at
first we're just handling all the debt
except the mortgage so I think if for
the time being you kind of set the
mortgage on the shelf and don't be
concerned with that just look at the
other bit of debt that you've got the
other uh 70,000 that's here um that's
what I'd be concerned about and with
your income I think it's just as simple
as getting on a budget and figuring out
how much you can put towards this every
month does that look like extra side
hustles I think right now you're
overwhelmed because you're adding the
mortgage into it is that fair right uh
yeah and how far into the total when
makeover book are
you a couple chapters but I've been
listening to your show for okay so well
baby step you know baby step one is save
$1,000 when you get there two is to do
what Jade is saying and that's pay off
your debts everything but your house
smallest to largest and you've got
$76,000 of that and you make $1
146,000 and so technically speaking if
you were to live on 70,000 not counting
taxes you'd be debt free in one year mhm
I like that but you won't you you do
have taxes and you might not do that so
it might take you two years but much
less than two years you should be debt
free except your mortgage in baby step
two um can I ask you a follow-up
question on the mortgage payment
sure um so they so I have TMI on this do
you do you ever um would you ever advise
anyone to quickly pay down as much as
they can to get the PMI taken off to
free up some extra or just
strictly keep that on the back burner
until you get I mean technically I would
keep it on the back burner yeah i' put
it in baby step six here's the thing if
you're if you're out of baby step two in
18 months and you do take another six
months to finish your emergency fund
then you're going to start doing four
five and six
simultaneously so I mean we're talking
two years or something you're going to
start to attack yourk morage mhm so
that's going to get rid of the PMI
faster than it would if you screw around
with all this stuff at one time that's
right so no I I I think you just sit
there and pay the mortgage enjoy the
house and work your tail end off and
live on nothing you better really enjoy
the house cuz you don't need to leave
it you don't need to go out to eat you
don't need to go on vacation you don't
need to be doing anything you need to be
attacking this
$76,000 of other debt and deciding if
you have a car you need to sell or not
and just attack attack attack attack
attack right you know he read The Total
Money Makeover he got excited about what
he read and the the key is get excited
like you do start feeling the weight of
the debt but don't let it cause you to
go in the wrong direction and go in the
opposite directions of what the the
steps are teaching do you know what I'm
saying like I could tell he's excited
but just follow the steps yeah it's the
fastest way at the end of the story the
fastest way to to Building Wealth is to
follow these baby steps and it's not
like we just made this stuff up in I
think tank somewhere m i mean we've sold
10 million Total Money Makeover books
we've had 10 million people go through
Financial Peace University all of that
is the baby steps some of those are the
same person some of them bought more
than one book and so forth but it's not
it's not necessarily 20 million people
but my goodness a lot of folks have done
this stuff and have become millionaires
we call those baby steps millionaires
Luc is in Cleveland Ohio Luke welcome to
the Ramsey Show hi Dave thank you for
having me sure what's up um so I'm a
19-year-old in college and I have some
student loans um not too worried about
them um I have no debt um and I was
basically kind of wondering where what
you would recommend me to uh do to
either avoid student loans or pay off
the few student loans that I have um and
then post student loans to um just build
my wealth where are you going to school
uh Ohio Wesleyan University in uh
Columbus area and what's that cost you
so far in student loans how much have
you taken out so far I would say about
6,000 Max okay and is that per
semester uh that's for um the past three
semesters that I've been there okay so
yeah so it's nothing ex it's nothing
exponential so so work 40 to 60 hours a
week and pay for
school okay um so my plan after college
is to um go to med school so I know
that's a big uh um builds a lot of debt
and obviously student loans so no not
obviously well I think you have to
change your mindset because to answer
the core of your question how to go to
school without student loans is you go
to school without student loans so you
have to take that off the table and I
can tell by the way you're talking in
the words that you're using that in your
mind somewhere it's still an option and
in some somewhere in your mind it's
still kind of like the only and best
option and you've really got to change
that so if I'm you first and foremost
I'm going to finish undergrad like Dave
said I'm paying my way through and then
you need to start researching programs
that will pay for your school as you're
going to school and you need to start
researching programs where you can get
your degree and maybe you're not going
to that top dollar state school maybe
you're going you know to a smaller
school that's less less expensive so
just do your due diligence on this yeah
and there's things called MD PHD
programs where you can actually go to
work for the University and then your
tuition's free while you're studying for
MD there's this neat thing called the
military and they will pay for it uh and
you will serve them for a while and
serve your country in other words uh
there are ways to go through and become
a doctor um there are even some of the
hospitals now that are paying for it
because uh but of course you're going to
promise to work there for a period of
years afterwards but that's a great
trade they're going to pay you when you
work there so you want to look at these
things and start poking around on those
things Luke be very careful of your
language out of the abundance of the
heart the mouth speaks that's a Bible
scripture okay and earlier you said I
don't have any debt and then you said I
have student loans which means that you
don't even think student loans are debt
right and um I do think they're debt as
a matter of fact I'm really sure they're
debt and you need to avoid them and I
appreciate your call kind of hard to be
on a radio show it's be nervous you can
say things but I understand but um no
you're right you're right yeah but you
know you want to be real real careful to
choose to avoid this and and okay I've
got a new goal in addition to going to
med school I'm going to med school debt
free ooh that's a cool goal hey man
thanks for being a listener this is the
Ramsey
[Music]
Show
hey guys I've told you before about
Christian Healthcare Ministries a health
cost sharing Ministry but listen to
Jenna a chm member she says one of my
biggest concerns about entrepreneurship
and motherhood was figuring out how to
take care of our health expenses but we
have found a solution that works for us
in an incredible way she loves that with
chm she can help other families who need
it and receive help back when her own
family has an eligible medical event chm
has been a godsend for Jenna that's her
chm story and it could be yours learn
more and join at chministries.org
buget
[Music]
Jade washaw Ramsey personality is my
co-host today wow wow wow thank you guys
you're amazing out there so let me ask
ask you a question before I tell you why
you're amazing what percent of Americans
say their personal finances have a
negative impact on their mental
health
49% of Americans say their finances have
a negative impact on their mental health
a jump from the previous quarter and two
in five Americans have experienced
anxiety attacks due to money stress
money stress is real and you know what
what happens is we get stuck we just
keep doing the same stupid thing over
and over again expect a different result
which is the definition of insanity we
know that and if you want to get
something you've never gotten you got to
do something you've never done we know
that so you got to break the cycle right
cuz stupid has a gravitational pull
it'll hold you in its orbit you can just
get stuck circling stupid and the only
way you can get out of that stupid orbit
is to expend energy that's how you break
in orbit you have to fire all the
rockets and break away yeah so we're
going to help you break the cycle and
man are we doing it big time this is
what the thank you is for so we started
telling you guys about this free live
stream that Jade and I are doing tonight
along with Dr John deloney Rachel Cruz
and George camel and now over
400,000 of
you that's the mo that's the biggest one
we've ever done Wow have signed up to
watch tonight thank you wow I hope you
actually watch MH because if you watch
someone 10 of you out of 400,000 the
odds aren't real good but 10 of you are
going to win $1,000 each we're going to
give away $10,000 to people actually
viewing come on the event tonight and
you can still come and watch it and
still be one of those 10 possibly uh but
it's going to be great I mean we've been
walking through the the content pieces
and uh with what Rachel and uh Jade are
doing around every dollar what George is
doing around the ripoffs that are out
there and Dr delone is doing around the
anxiety issues and me just stirring up
trouble which is like my spiritual gift
so hey come and join us we'd love to
have you go to ramseys solutions.com
breakthe cycle and you can register and
watch this live event live stream
tonight it's at 700 p.m. central Time
Thursday the 11th for those of you
tuning in at whatever time you tune in
so however this works in your world so a
lot of people are live on our YouTube
feed a lot of people are live on uh some
of our other feeds and then of course
there's a bazillion of you on podcast
and they hear the show later so you may
just have fomo on this but um we would
love to have you it's going to be
incredible we're very proud of what's
going to happen tonight we are going to
help
you really we've been doing it for 30
years we're going to help you break the
cycle and break that orbit around stupid
Aisha Is With Us in Atlanta hi a welcome
to the Ramsey
Show uh hey Dave hey Jade pretty close
it's pronounced Alicia oh I'm so sorry
they had it correct on my screen and I
screwed it up I'm I'm kind of legendary
for screwing up names what's up how can
I help that's okay uh so I'm recently
into real estate I got my license back
in April um I sold my first half a
million within my first six months so
I'm very proud of that and I'm I'm
finding a hard
time getting
buyers to their pre-approved status
while trying to help them get out of
debt and uh I'm trying to work with you
know lenders and everything like that so
I was trying to figure out pi to brain
the best way to look at you know gaining
more clientele and encouraging them when
they're ready to
buy good job that's awesome that you're
even thinking about it like that yeah
well done well done so uh uh we teach
people to not buy until you are
debt-free and have your emergency fund
in place so don't don't send them to us
if you want them to buy while they've
got debt because we're going to mess up
your sale true that so um first thing
but but the uh but if they're if if
they're going to go that route um the
thing is this I generally let's just say
how do I talk to someone
about difficult subject like money or
getting out of debt don't talk to them
about them talk to them about your
story just say I don't know about you
but a lot of people are like me and I
had this and this I had this debt I did
this stupid thing and I struggled this
way and it was hard for me and me and my
husband fought about money and whatever
the truth story is about the times that
you made a mistake and screwed up and
then you say but I Chang changed because
I started seeing the value of not having
any payments and I work my tail end off
and I sold stuff and it took me certain
amount of time and now I am dead for
it's your
story your story is an encouragement and
your story is not shaming to
others so uh I could lose about 20 25
PBS right now it'd be good for me uh
telling me I'm fat is probably not going
to motivate me but I ran into one of the
guys working here Tim have you seen Tim
Yeah Tim Tim has lost like he was a big
old boy he lost like 100 pounds he lost
a backstreet boy I mean he's he has he
he looks like a completely different
person and just seeing Tim yeah
motivates me then I talk to Tim about
his story it motivates me but it's not
Tim coming up and going you know Dave
you know Dave you could lose a few pound
you you could really you you fit better
behind that old desk over there you know
and so so that's the thing I think that
works really good with a lot of ways to
convert a lot of people to a lot of
things absolutely I like talking to
people about Jesus but I don't want to
wag beat them over the head with the
Bible I talk about what Jesus did for me
yeah then you're talking to them you're
not talking at them and you're not kind
of putting yourself in a higher position
right yeah you don't want to talk down
although Tim could do that cuz Tim's
also tall but anyway but yeah that
you're right you're right that's big
thing cuz the this subject is not unlike
being fat it's a it's a it's a
shaming very sensitive it's a shaming it
has a lot of condemnation with it and
those kinds of things and so you've got
to just be real careful to not wag your
finger in any way and not go well you
know if You' quit doing that stupid
stuff now when people call here it's
different CU they're asking us they
called our phone if you ask me now I've
got to tell you cuz that's like my job
right yeah you called the number yeah
you dialed it up baby so don't don't
call here and ask for our opinion cuz
we'll give it to you we are experts on
our opinion you know but the uh uh but
but do you know when you're dealing with
your friends and relatives and things I
don't I wouldn't go in there talking
about the other stuff at all I would
just talk about you and just go I don't
know if this helps you or not but when I
was facing a thing like this and um you
know that that helps to just not you
know kind of kind of pull yourself back
back a little bit I think so especially
when you're in a position like her they
trust they trust her to a certain degree
because they chose her as the realtor so
she's already has that position of trust
and I think you're right if you choose
your words carefully you can grow that
with them but the moment you kind of
like you said start wagging your finger
then it starts to dissipate and you
start to lose your footing with that
person so it is very important how you
approach uh subjects like money and
weight loss well all I mean anything
religion anything you want to talk about
I mean you know nobody has ever been had
their mind Changed by someone just
randomly starting to yell at them I mean
it's like as if that works on the
internet too it doesn't work I mean like
you know all these 47,000 haters they
changed my life you know not at all they
didn't change my life at all I don't
even know they're there right you know
that's it so that's the whole process
Jade washaw Ramsey personality is my
co-host today her quick read has sold
out and we're just getting some new ones
in so you can get them money's not a
math problem the real reason you're
broke and what to do about it and that
has to do with just exactly what we're
talking about yeah the person the person
in your mirror The Man in the Mirror
Michael Jackson said it best I mean most
of us Dave we have this ticker tape you
ever watch the news and there's that
ticker tape that's rolling in the
background that's telling you what's
going on most of us have that in our
minds and it's affecting our actions our
behavior and we're not really aware of
it until we take the time to stop and
read it and understand okay this is what
what I've been thinking this whole time
that's why I'm behaving this way so that
book is all about uh addressing your
belief system and changing the beliefs
that are untrue and not serving you
there you go money's not a math problem
with Jade baraw you'll enjoy it I
promise this is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show
hey guys Ramsey solution started small
and grew fast because of that rapid
growth there were times when our systems
slowed us down that's why we switch to
netw Suite it works for us and it'll
help your business too whether you're
starting on a card table like I did or
you're well on your way to becoming a
multi-million doll company netsuite can
scale with you and help you communicate
and plan better because you know your
day-to-day up and down and sideways but
accounting analytics and supply chain
are on another level so maybe you're
just not techsavvy that can be okay net
Suite will help at your speed and
whatever your situation more than
37,000 companies use netsuite to know
their numbers and their business better
so check out netw Suite today and find
out how they can help you become the
business you want to be five or 30 years
from now and right now you can download
Net's free kpi checklist designed to
give you consistently excellent
performance at netsuite.com Ramsey
that's netsuite.com
[Music]
Ramsey
Jade washaw Ramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
Michael and Jill are on the debt free
stage hey guys how are you good good
doing great good good to have you guys
welcome where do you live Phoenix
arizota oh fun welcome to Nashville
thank you and how much debt have you
paid off
$570,000 oh that's all wow and how long
did that take 45 months or
1,373
days that's awesome I love it and your
range of income during that 1373 days uh
170 to over 200 nice good for you guys
what do youall do for a living I'm in
law enforcement I'm a director of
administration at how realy ah very good
good for you guys and what kind of debt
pray tell was
$570,000 uh it was the house we live in
with our two kids y look at at weird
people I love it that's a beautiful
house very cool a paid for house what is
this house worth about 800,000 let's go
love it and how much in your nest eggs
uh just over a million a little bit more
all right so million eight net worth
baby steps millionaires yes sir way to
go you two that's awesome law
enforcement and administration to there
we go and that's how we did it so way to
go you guys how old are y'all I'm in my
early 50s I'm in my mid 40s amazing very
cool and and uh debt free and
millionaires yes sir all because of you
man I I didn't pay any of it you guys
are heroes we've been following you for
23 years wow okay great well tell us the
story what happened uh 45 months ago
that made the made the house get uh in
the gun sites sure well uh I didn't want
to move but she wanted to move and I
said okay if we're going to move to a
new house we're going to pay it off in 5
years and uh we did it in three years
and 9 months and uh we've been debt free
for years like she said but and we've
been following you for years but you
know the mortgage was was always the the
big last hurdle and we just buckled down
and spent 2third of our income uh on the
house on the mortgage we sold some stuff
I sold my 69 Mustang Fastback yeah um we
I sold some guns um you know we did some
sold some stuff and uh just spent all
our almost two-thirds of our income on
the mortgage so wait a minute you bought
the house three three years and nine
months ago and paid it off in 3 years
and 9 months ma' holy moly wow yep wow
but that was the deal that the deal I'm
not moving unless we're paying it off
right I'm shook that's amazing so Jill
he comes in with this deal and you just
said game on I did yes I want the house
game on game on we're going to live on
nothing and we're going to be done yes
sir and not even four years later
correct you do the 5year goal amazing
wow beans and rice rice and beans for
the house yep yes hey okay yeah but
we're worth a million eight and the
house is paid for in freaking Phoenix
which is an incredibly good real estate
market way to go y'all how's it feel
feels great feels great I'm very proud
stressfree liberating yeah liberating
for sure um I I want to brag about it a
little bit too go go on and do it it's a
good place to do it we like bragging
here it wasn't easy but it was
definitely definitely worth it yeah I
tell you to take your shoes off and walk
through the grass in the backyard but
it' be sand that's
right oh my gosh you guys I'm so proud
of you thank you way to go way to go
what do you tell people the key to doing
something like this is cuz that's a
pretty bizarre move budget Bud teamw
team sacrifice yeah yes wow you realized
at some point um maybe even before this
and just applied the principle that the
biggest thing standing between someone
and hitting their goals is not what they
have to do to get there it's what they
have to give up to get there yes so the
guns the fastb Mustang I mean like I
want this goal I want this goal to the
exclusion of other things yes bringing
my work uh bringing my lunch to work
every day making my own coffee doing my
own Nails every Sunday not getting my
hair done professionally she does the
Landscaping I do the Landscaping pluging
I kill the bugs uh you know I kill the
weeds we do all those things we can so
we don't have to pay someone else to do
it and we're not very handy so it's
usually for yourself I'm pretty handy
she's pretty handy that's an adventure
wow you know I did that I started doing
my own hair it looks like doesn't it
look like it well it looks like it shut
up J just shut up you you lost a few
strands Dave missed a spot missed a
spot ah you guys man that's that's
powerful very cool now what's the first
big thing you're going to do with money
to enjoy it now that this is here well
we bought a hot tub yes yeah bought a
hot tub and we're going to the Caribbean
with some friends in a couple of months
and we're going to take our kids on a
cruise this summer they've sacrificed a
lot too they have I like wow living like
no one else stepen and Emily have
definitely U Been our big cheerleaders
as well and helped and how old are they
uh 20 and 18 oh perfect so they got to
watch Mom and Dad do something hard up
up close and personal yes it's crazy uh
they have all the baby STS memorized
they're definitely uh been indoctrinated
uh both of them work at Chick-fil-A and
they have more in their bank accounts
now saved than I did when I was 30
before we got married and they're 20 in
2018 yes sir wow I like wow hey can you
speak to because the housing market has
people up on end right and I'm looking
at okay $570,000 house you said you're
in that was the mortgage $800,000 house
well now it's worth $800,000 right oh
wow so speak to people who are
frustrated by the housing market they're
in their mid 20s and they feel like they
need to have the house today and it's
it's too expensive for them talk to them
from your perspective of what this
journey looks like well this is our
fourth house so you know we move M up
moved up every 8 years and uh we always
get the the 15E fixed mortgage um we
never stayed in anyone long long enough
to pay it off um that's my fault that's
her fault she apparently every 8 years
she wants to move we're never moving
again I told him this is it we're never
moving again we we've been liking I
promise Dave never yeah right we've been
liking Tennessee so much maybe we'll get
a second house out here listen you can
you can do it now yeah wow exciting
start small a lot of people I think they
they believe they have to have this huge
house and this
with theones and you just need to buy
what you need and what you what you need
and what you can afford that's right
yeah that's what you did here and you
did something you could put in the you
know put in the sites where we could do
it in 5 years knock it out boom yes sir
cuz you rolled some Equity into this
obviously yes yeah so good very good you
guys very good anything you can think of
you say if someone asks me about this
I'm always going to tell them about
getting out of debt always do this
follow the baby steps I mean you've
you've already paved the road we just
walked it um like I said we've been dead
free for years but the the mortgage was
always you know step seven or step six
and we
just focused on it really just that was
the only thing we hadn't done and we
wanted to do it while our kids to live
at home and you know in school and um we
want to show them it's possible yeah you
did way to go you guys hey we've got the
live and give box for you it's got the
baby steps millionaires book in it
because you are one The Total Money
Makeover book uh cuz you are One
Financial Peace University cuz you are
one and so I guess you'll be giving all
that away or maybe you can keep the one
I signed in a few minutes and give
another one way I don't care whatever
you want but uh way to go you guys
you're you're perfect you're amazing
thank so so proud of you you're absolute
Heroes taking control of your lives
Michael and Jill Phoenix Arizona $1.8
million net worth living in an $800,000
house they paid off
$570,000 house and
everything making 170 to 200 they did it
in 45 months count it down let's hear a
dead free Scream 3 2 one we're dead
[Applause]
free wow you got to love it got to love
it that's amazing incredible and and you
know we've heard these stories for
decades around here and so it makes us
know way deep down in our bones cuz
we've just witnessed it that it can be
done and so we just want to make sure
all of you know it can be done and
that's one of the reason we continue to
do debt-free screams and um because each
one of these stories has something
special about it yeah deep sacrifice I
love it listen you don't have to
sacrifice that deeply to pay off a home
but the fact that they chose to do that
is really really cool to me look at
where it puts some net worth wise and
cash flow wise I mean they're making a
couple 100 not a payment in the world oh
man you got some money you stack some
cash now man all right you got Cho and
we got an 18 and 20-year-old well on
their way to being millionaires I mean
uh that's talking about mathematically
but Also spiritually and from a behavior
standpoint changing your family tree
because those two youngsters witnessed
their parents doing hard things yeah
it's a big deal it's a really big deal
this is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show
hey if you're in over your head with
Stud student loans and tired of getting
calls from collection agencies if
private student loan debt is taking away
your financial piece and you don't see
any way out you need why refi they're
not a debt settlement company and
they're not connected to a bank why refi
refinances defaulted private student
loans that other places won't touch and
gives you a custom loan built for you
based on your ability to pay so when you
refinance your private student loan debt
with Y refi you'll have a payment you
can afford with a low fixed interest
rate you couldn't get anywhere else to
help you stick to your budget and work
the debt snowball and you can save
thousands of dollars to learn more about
this custom refinancing option and a
lumpsum payoff option you could qualify
for after 24 months call
8442 Ramsey or go to y refi.com
[Music]
[Applause]
Ramsey Jade washaw Ramsey personality is
my co-host today our question of the day
is brought to you by neighborly your hub
for Home Services whether your holiday
guests left your home in a shambles or
you just need some help getting caught
up a locally owned Molly made can help
start the new year off right with
professional trustworthy made services
that deliver a WorryFree experience go
to neighbor.com Ramsey today all right
today's question comes from Terry in
North Carolina my wife and I have worked
hard we paid off our debt and have a net
worth of 8 million we still watch every
dollar and save and invest as much as
possible my brother and his wife do not
follow the same strategy recently my
brother approached me for some money
because he has failed to pay taxes for
years and the IRS is threatening to put
a lean on his house he now owes over a
100,000 that I know about I believe in
helping family so I have given him over
23,000 and I plan to give him another 8K
soon I created a budget for him set up
separate accounts to help avoid reflex
spending and even recommended he listen
to your podcast things went well for a
month but I found out he and his wife
majorly overspent on gifts during the
holidays My worry is that my help has
been a waste he doesn't seem to
recognize the damage that he is doing to
our relationship by essentially spending
my money on frivolous items while I keep
the IRS off his back he also doesn't
seem to understand that every dollar I
give him is one I can't invest myself
should I just walk away at this point
I'm going to say yes um Let me let me
back up my position on this
Dave I'm looking at some of the language
that you're using and what I see here is
resentment building because clearly you
don't like the way he's living his life
I like that you're giving him the money
and not loaning it to him but because in
your mind there's these strings attached
that he's not following I feel like it's
causing it's causing unrest in you and
in your spirit I'm like listen you got
to guard your heart a little bit because
if you keep giving him money and he
continues to not do what you think he
should do it's just going to build up
your anger towards him your resentment
towards him I mean you said it right
here you said um let's see he keeps
spending my money while I'm keeping the
irs's off his back he it's like you're
does that do you hear that Dave where
he's getting angry and I also what I
also see here is you're trying to do
everything for for him and as long as
you do things for him he has to do
nothing for himself listen he got to
have a great Christmas because you gave
him the money and you know it doesn't
say this written here but if you're just
handing him checks for money that yeah
that's not going to work maybe you reach
in and pay something off for him but
just just giving him 23,000 and 8,000
you don't know what he's spending that
on if this was my
brother I would say I love you and I'm
cheering for you
and I will give you encouragement and
advice but no more money no more I'm
done because the money that I've given
you has not helped you you've not made
any adjustments what you did at
Christmas was frankly ridiculous and
insulting MH after I tried to help you
and gave you money you went out and
acted like a
four-year-old and so I love you I'm
going to cheer you on to the extent you
want my help I'm here to help you but it
won't be with any more checks yep it has
nothing to do with my net worth or my
level of generosity and by the way there
is zero moral or ethical obligation to
give someone money just because they're
in your
family
zero
none none we all like to help people we
love whether they're in our family or
not but the but are we really helping
someone when we're giving a drunk a
drink no and all you did was give him a
big old bottle of Jack Daniels and he
and got trashed he got trashed but I
feel like the the the brother who's
trying to give the money he's trashing
himself too because he it's well he's
the only grownup in the equation yeah I
mean little little brother or whatever
he is is acting like he's four freaking
years old I mean who responds to a gift
by going out and a me you know helping
with money by and after you know the giv
Giver of the gift says okay here's a
podcast here's a budget here's separate
account
and the way and here's some money and
you know we're going to stand you up and
we're going to put you on roller skates
and push you down the road and here we
go and what do you do you take the
skates off and throw them back at him I
mean come on that's why I say if you
can't walk away and just kind of shake
your hands and walk away don't don't do
it I wouldn't I wouldn't stop speaking
to him I would tell him you love him and
I'd be there for him and help him but
that you are not required to give
someone who is misbehaving money and you
shouldn't because your Finance ing the
misbehavior it's called enabling
Nathan's with us in Austin Texas hi
Nathan how are you hi I'm doing well how
are you better than I deserve what's
up yes so I've been listening for a
couple of weeks now um my wife and I
built up a little bit of debt over the
years mainly in credit cards and we are
committed to um creating that debt
snowball and paying it all off um but at
the same time we need to get her a
vehicle we have one vehicle right now
that I use for work and um we need to
get her one by August because my
daughter starts preschool where was have
you always been a one car
family um just for the last year or so
what happened to her
car um she no longer needed it we uh she
works from home um and watches our
daughter so we had a car payment we were
paying on on um and so you sold it to
get rid of the car payment sold it got
rid of the car payment and they actually
paid us a little bit on it you weird
time where I'm driving a paid off
vehicle what is
it it's a Chevy Equinox what's your
commute so I it depends I'm in sales so
I drive as far as an hour to an hour and
a half away or sometimes I'm just you
her thing is she got to take K to
school right okay what do you make
what's your household income so last
year we made
105,000 together all right gross so if
you saved up $3,000 and and didn't put
that on debt and went and bought a
little car would that be
okay I think that would be okay you know
I've been looking for vehicles in the
area um things I'm finding are more in
the $5,000 range that's cuz you weren't
looking for a
3,000 there's lots of
3,000 okay okay it doesn't need to be
anything fancy how much debt have y'all
got
left so we have uh about $220,000 of
debth um we have 6,000 in student loans
and the rest is in credit
cards okay so if you're going to lean in
and get this paid off really fast then
you can move up in car after you get
your emergency fund in place and this is
a temporary solution I would I'm not
suggesting you ask your wife to drive a
3 ,000 car for the rest of her life but
for the next uh 18 months yeah listen if
all she's doing is picking up the kids
and going to the grocery store that'll
get it done all it's got to do is run m
not leak right yeah and there's plenty
there's plenty of $3,000 cars out there
I mean an old Camry that's in good shape
you know even if it's 150,000 Mi or
whatever maybe it's got a ding in it who
cares and you know that's okay again
this is an 18month car it's not a
lifetime car
okay so should we not should we just
pause the debt snowball and you have
$3,000 yeah two or $3,000 okay yeah
couple thousand bucks 3,000 bucks Max
and then go get you a little something
that's kind of ugly but reliable and you
get it's the kind of car you give it a
name it's called a hoopie right it has
special features has special features
this is Old Blue yeah when I was growing
up we had old blue my mama had a u a
Chevy 2 it was called it was a Chevy 2
Nova 1963 Nova and it um had air
conditioning it was 240 air conditioning
we rolled down two windows and went 40 m
hour so there you go you know what they
say about novas it it's Nova means no go
like that's the worst way the worst car
name ever oh wow I didn't know that okay
now this car is a it was a good little
car as a matter of fact the brand the
rebuilt ones that are very cool they
little hot rods now the Antiques rebuilt
I saw one the other day that I almost
bought but yeah they're they're Pretty
stinking cool but yeah yeah you just get
an old car that needs a name uh we've
had we had old blue at one time and um
we had the Bondo buggy once you got to
have something you got to have
something's got a name and it's just for
18 months it's kind of a part of the
adventure of sacrificing to get out of
debt and then you go get a better car
and you pay cash and you move up in car
and you pay cash and you pay cash and
you avoid debt and you get out of debt
and you pay cash and then you're a
millionaire just like that that's how
that
works this is the Ramsey
[Music]
[Applause]
Show
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsy
solutions it's the ramsy show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relation reltionship Jade washaw Ramsey
personality author of the bestselling
book money is not a math problem is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
the phone number is
88255 225 Steve is in Louisville
Kentucky hi Steve welcome to the Ramsey
Show hey Dave thank you so much for uh
having me on the show I'm a longtime
listener great fan and you have helped
me more than more ways that you know sir
well thank you I'm honored how can we
help well sir um
I am going through a divorce after five
years of marriage and we have four kids
uh four girls yes um one child we have
together and the other three are from
our previous marriages you know I
brought in two she brought in one um but
my wife has decided to to end it to call
it quiz she's already moved out we just
started the separation process and uh
decided to just split everything down
the middle 50/50 you know to avoid Court
fees and all that so um it's just moved
so fast within the time that she's moved
out we've already sold the house and
that was only like two weeks ago yeah we
we posted it and immediately it it got a
hit so we've got it's it's currently
under
contract um we sold our our vehicle our
van that we had together it was all paid
for so my question is it's a horrible
situation but I'm just trying to clean
it up and and uh make it as less
damaging as possible I have three kids
to raise
um uh I'm going to walk away and she's
going to walk away with approximately
140k after all the realer fees um we
sold it for 435 we only owed 150 on it
and you have no debt and with the van no
debt we U I'm on baby step four through
six currently contributing 15% to my
retirement um now I will be honest I
have not put anything away from my kids
college I was getting around to that and
so my question is with this with this
money um it's already an emotional
roller coaster and I I've heard what you
said in the past about not making big
decisions within like a year if I get
that right so I don't want to make any
big decisions I want to protect this
money from myself from doing anything
stupid so I just wanted to put it like
in a CD or a high yield savings account
maybe even Ju Just park it away and
don't touch it for a year uh currently
like I said got a 20K and a just a high
yield savings account right now for
emergencies um but I'm tempted I've had
a lot of friends tell me well you need
to immediately go buy a smaller house
and I've looked into house housing
prices and lo and behold even smaller
houses in this area are just as just you
know the mortgage would be just as much
as what I'm currently paying U you know
selling this home what do you what do
you make so um I make 70k uh at gross
um you've been married five years and
you both have kids so you're 30
something I'm 42 I kind of started your
program a little late okay I'm just
trying to figure out where you were
based on your kids and marriages and
stuff okay um all right so um the child
you guys have together is are they
primarily living with
you 5050 ma'am uh we've got a 223 split
so we're she's only four years old okay
so she's right in the middle of it okay
um I I don't know that you have rent
something for a year we're usually
talking about a death in that situation
um but I do think your life is probably
going to shake out and still be
reforming still be Clay on the wheel for
at least 6 months so I'd probably just
go find you a nice rental for 6
months and and then let's see where we
are you know at the end of
summer and by then let's check your
emotions and see where you are that 140
will be sitting there in a CD put it in
a 6- Monon CD and and just go about the
business of earning a living and set up
the rhythm of your new life right and uh
and let's see where that leads you
um you know we don't I don't know where
your ex is going to land in terms of
running the kid back and forth um and
all those kinds of things that might
have now probably wouldn't have much
influence on it if it was me but but you
know I'm just thinking about what you
know what all can happen uh you know uh
but I I I would give it six months and
just let it sit and kind of percolate
and let's get the let the dust settle so
to
speak yes yes sir
okay there's no harm in that the only
thing that could hurt you there is if
price house prices are going to go up
during that six
months right that that's that's what one
of my friends was telling me he said
even with the interest rates now is
buyers Market you need to get a house
now he's right he's right about that but
the timing's not right for you
ah okay even though the market timing is
it's a good time to buy it's a really
good time to buy but uh but I I wouldn't
I I still wouldn't because of your
situation nothing to do with the real
estate
market okay now that makes sense yeah
just give yourself a little room to heal
a little you'll make a different
decision with six months of healing
under your belt I think so and I think
you made a good point about kind of
seeing where all the cards land because
he doesn't know where his ex-wife is
going to end up and there is some
practicality to I don't know yeah and
and there's probably a relationship in
his life in the future but I don't know
when but um and you don't think about
that right now when you're sitting in
the middle of a broken heart right so um
I just take your time take your time
you're gonna be fine Jonathan is in Salt
Lake City hey Jonathan how are
you hi there Mr Ramsey and Mrs warshaw
thank you so much for taking my call
sure what's
up so I am calling my question is should
I be looking at life insurance right now
and if so how much and what term uh the
background to the question is I am
currently a dental student um my wife
and I have no debt um we're not taking
out student loans to pay for school um
and we are expecting our first child
little halfway through this year how are
you paying for
dental uh so before I started dental
school we actually both saved up a good
chunk of money uh both with our own on
our own as well as with some help from
our parents wow um that was originally
going to be used for a down payment on
our house um we decided to repurpose
that money and use it to help get
through dental school without taking out
good chunk of money way to go man proud
of you yes yes sir yes sir yes thank you
so if you die how does your wife
eat so and if really kind of depends on
when of course if you die now if you die
this year you're while you're in dental
school while you're in dental school how
does she eat how's your kid eat my wife
has a job um so she makes about our
take-home pay is about $44,000 a month
um and so she does have that we also of
course have the money that we're using
to pay for dental school which right now
between our emergency fund and our
savings account is about
170,000 so that's that's what we would
have right now and that's what she would
have okay all right and you're how
old I'm 25 are
you yes sir are you
overweight no sir do you
smoke no sir go buy a million dollars in
term it's the cost of a pizza and cost
anything just make sure your family's
taken care of by 15year level go to
Xander insurance.com it's a 5-year-old
didn't cost a thing man it's nothing
Now's the Time this is the Ramsey
[Music]
show if you're like most people your
home is your most valuable asset and
when you want to make improvements it
can feel like everything costs too much
or take too long but something as simple
as custom window coverings from
blinds.com can completely change your
space and add value to your home we've
recommended blinds.com for over a decade
so you know you can trust them from
blinds drapes and shutters to motorized
Shades they make it easy and affordable
to upgrade your entire home and their
team is ready to help with everything
from design consultation to measuring
and and installation plus there are
never any misleading quotes or hidden
fees everything's backed by their 100%
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free Cy blinds.com is the number
one online retailer of custom window
coverings visit blinds.com to get up to
45% off that's blinds.com rules and
restrictions May
apply
[Music]
Jade washaw Ramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you America we
appreciate appreciate all of your help
these these ramsy shows are shown up on
all the different podcast platforms from
Spotify to Apple to Google to whatever
any way you listen to them we're also
big deal on YouTube and um the number
two talk radio show in America on 680
radio stations all of that is caused by
you guys spreading the word and sharing
we were number one on Apple recently on
all Apple podcasts we've had a bill ion
downloads of this show now wow that just
blows my little bitty brain I just thank
you guys thank you so much we appreciate
you so how can you help us further we
really do need your help we want to keep
this ball rolling and keep helping
people and you're pretty much our
marketing budget so click on subscribe
click on follow it helps a lot um leave
a nice five-star review it helps a lot
and uh if it's got a if your platform
has a share feature share the show or
just make a copy of the link or just use
your mouth and tell people I listen to
the such and such a radio station that's
fine however it is share the show leave
a nice review follow subscribe like all
those little internet things that you do
you know you know those games you play
and we need your help please do that
Billy is with us Billy's in Long Island
New York hi Billy how are
you I'm doing good how are you guys
doing today better than we just serve
what's
up um I so I have a quick question for
you guys I've been uh just really
starting to get you know into listening
to you guys and really kinding to hone
down on my finances the past like I
would say past couple of months and kind
of getting a better understanding of
where I'm at good um so my question for
you guys is I'm 27 years old I am still
living at home with my father I have no
issue with that though however I also
would like to move out you know that's
kind of normal to do at this point of
age you know but yeah sure the housing
market in New York is insane so my
question for you is I don't know what to
do I don't know when to move out I don't
know if there's a specific time should I
keep waiting I mean I I could certainly
afford an apartment and stuff like that
but I view that as something that is fun
to do but just really just a money
drainer and it just there's no point do
you have any debt like what's your
financial
situation so right now I have uh I mean
I have a lease vehicle but I mean that's
totally under you know control no it's
not it's about $300 if it's under
control you would have paid for it true
okay so you got the least vehicle up but
yeah it's it's $300 a month um what do
you uh I make about 75k a year okay any
other debt I have about no I have about
75k in savings right now MH
great and I have about
25ish in my retirement right now so
what's stopping you like when you when
you get ready to pull the trigger on
this what holds you back and says Ah I'm
not going to do it because you've got
the
money yeah um I I just don't know if
there if now is a good time to do this I
don't know if two years ago was a good
time to do right do it yeah that that
was the thing it's time to go missed I
no I I'm not talking about the real
estate market I'm talking about just
life I'm talking about Billy and Long
Island when you were 25 it was a good
time to move out so let's go let's go
it's time you're just comfortable go go
get you a place it it's not because you
don't like your dad and it's not because
it's not a good idea to save money both
of those things can be true but there's
something that happens when you have
your own place and you're paying your
own light bill and you have to buy bread
or there's not
any it just changes everything yeah and
um you know it it is really good for
your personal
development your your psychological
emotional development to have your own
situation and it's not about out there
having a party that's not what we're
talking about we're just talking about
being a grownup and um yeah it's good
for you it's really good for you my
pastor says the comfort zone is a great
place but nothing ever grows there O So
way to go Dave if you want to grow her
pastor's name her your former Pastor
Dave his name is Dave too yeah great guy
he's a good friend yeah yeah he's right
he's exactly right nothing grows there
nothing grows and so get out there and
and scratch around get you it doesn't
have to be super expensive I just want
you to be standing literally on your own
two feet and um when you do that you're
just going to see things happen for you
mhm um you're going to see a different
version of yourself looking back in the
mirror yeah confidence and a good a good
one a good one yeah it builds confidence
it builds toughness uh and you know you
can buy a house in a couple years you
may even you know find it's okay you
don't there's no requirement for you to
buy a house quickly but someday you may
maybe you find the right person and you
get married and you buy a house that
might be too I don't know but um in the
meantime yeah I I think you're going
to uh walk differently you're going to
feel differently uh when you're standing
on your own and uh it's not a question
of can you save more money it's not a
question of his rent wasting your money
it's not a question of your relationship
with your dad all of those things to be
fine but I I I would just go
immediately uh within the next 2 or 3
months I'd be in a place if I were you
and give yourself a written deadline by
the time before the sun goes down today
write a date on the calendar that's good
that's good Dave write a date on the
calendar and by this date yeah and that
starts and tell someone about it yeah
yeah and tell somebody you did that yeah
but put you know by this date and that
starts the wheel moving in your brain it
ca your brain starts going oh we've got
to look for a place and right you know
you'll you'll start running across
things you'll see a forent sign on the
way to work that you didn't see
yesterday and all that and tell your dad
tell your dad that you're moving out
yeah yeah and you know how much you
appreciate what he's done for you so far
MH and how much you love him and all
that that's all good because this is not
got anything to do with that some people
have to get out of the house because
it's a toxic disaster that's right he
seems like he's fine he's very
comfortable where he that's a little bit
of the problem yeah that is the problem
yeah that is the problem Jim is in
Jacksonville Florida hi Jim how are you
hey Dave how are you doing better than I
deserve what's
up yes sir um I got a question for you
and a uh sort of what would you do in my
predicament uh sort of question um I
have a very Hefty goal in mind I do want
to retire my parents by the time I
turned 26 and hopefully have enough in
the end to make me a millionaire as well
did you say retire your
parents yes ma'am what's that mean why
is that your
job well they they've done a lot for me
my entire life and I'd like to pay them
back it's not your
job well I I wouldn't necessarily say a
job but it's a goal of mine you're
you're 26 how you're not 26 how old are
you I'm
21 well hey can I just put this in your
mind you're when parents take care of
their kids they do it because that's
we're supposed to do it's not a debt
that you owe us back later on in life
yes d i I understand but it's it's still
just a goal of mine um in the end but
right now I'm I'm 21 I dropped out of
college um six months in right after
high school I started my own excavation
company um and my financial situation
right now is I'm bringing in a around
20,000 a month okay um and I have about
a 100 in SA
great it doesn't change what I said
though okay so so what you want to pile
up cash and build wealth and be able to
help your mom and dad okay so how can we
help
right where would you put um basically
liquid funds into something that would
make the the most of my return the first
uh and foremost I would get and stay
debt free uh secondly I would have an
emergency fund liquid in just a a high
yield savings account of three to six
months of expenses then thirdly and you
got you're ready to do this today
because you've already got all those
things covered I think uh I would sit
down with a smart Vester Pro and open
some mutual funds and start building
some wealth there and and Jim one more
time I'm going to challenge your goal I
think you need a different one I think
you need to make a have a goal of making
Jim wealthy and then one of the things
that future wealthy gy can do is be of
assistance to his parents but is not
your job nor is it a reasonable goal to
retire your parents that's their job
they're grown-ups and to the extent
they're unable to do that if you want to
assist them that's okay but I I I really
want you to have a goal of you being
whole first and foremost this is the
Ramsey
[Music]
Show
hey folks you know that sinking feeling
when you make an offer on a house you
love and then you hear there's another
offer you need the Churchill Mortgage
home buyer Edge super fast preapproval
and a secured interest rate plus a
$5,000 seller guarantee gives your offer
the best chance of being accepted the
home buyer Edge from Churchill gives you
an advantage over those other guys go to
Churchill mortgage.com today to learn
[Music]
more
thanks for being with us America Jade
washaw Ramsey personality is my co-host
Jared and Jennifer are with us they on
the debt free stage how are you guys
good great good to have you guys where
do you
live sparenberg South Carolina oh just
just over the hill that's a great town I
love sparenberg well welcome to
Nashville thanks for being here thanks
very cool how much debt have you paid
off
$255,000 love it how long did that take
forever oh sorry 6 years okay and your
range of income during that time started
around 130 and a little bit over 200 now
cool good what what do youall do for a
living um Jennifer I'm a pediatric
medical assistant awesome and I'm in
sales and packaging and have a little
motorcycle business on the side as well
like it very cool yeah
255,000 over 6 years what kind of debt
was that well it was the house and a
pickup truck
yeah
everything 100% weird people no debt at
all wow look at that house wow what's
this house
worth uh probably about
450,000 today's market I guess so yeah
very good yeah how much in you guys nest
egg in your in your retirement St a
little bit over 300,000 so we're
chugging we're chugging heading toward
heading towards millionaire way to go
that's right good job you guys good job
so what happened that put you guys on
this ramsy stuff about six years ago
well we want to go back just a little
bit further we started um our marriage
33 years ago and oh we didn't have much
Financial sense or Direction but Dave I
saw you on Oprah wow in 20 yeah way back
2005 and just your obviously your truth
and your demeanor I had to share it with
Jared and um we definitely used your
tools to you know take us along the way
but we really got serious the last six
years wow yeah way to go way to go very
cool yeah that was a bit ago that's
coming up on 20 years 2005 wow I
remember J saying you got to listen to
the Southerner he's pretty funny you're
going to like him you know but I went
downstairs to actually purchase the
program we watched it at 10:30 at night
cuz they would run Oprah twice in
Chicago and uh I got out my credit card
to purchase your program that's hilar
and it didn't work and I was like oh wow
this guy's legit real he's for real he
don't need your money yeah I like it for
you guys so I got to travel around with
the CDs just kind of pipe dreaming what
it would feel like you and now here you
are not a payment in the world amazing
amen and amen so what made you kind of
turn the switch on six years ago like
what made you go from 2005 I hear this
message I like it it makes sense but I'm
not ready to turn the switch what made
you turn the key yeah well the Lord U
the Lord has a way of pursuing you in a
way that uh for us it was really a
spiritual journey for me personally
especially and um God captivated me he
knew how to pursue me into an
intersection that I had to turn left I
should say I had to turn right and uh
and in doing that just everything
started come into alignment and um I'm
Living For The First Time in the life
more abundantly and and it feels so good
so um that actually Catalyst into uh
Ministry that we started um two plus
years ago make war Ministries and uh and
then the business with the motorcycles
I've been in motorcycles for since I was
11 I'm 54 now and um God gave me the
desires of my heart and that that
business actually helps fund the
ministry as well so it all just ties in
and it feels so good I love it there we
go and Jennifer can't quit grinning
right she's surprised as everybody she's
just loving this version you and this
life she's living that's right amen amen
yeah very cool very cool that's good
stuff guys that's very good stuff so
when someone's listening to this and
they say um how do you get your house
paid off at 54 I mean everything is paid
for heading towards millionaire what do
you tell them the secret to getting out
of debt is well the budget you know is a
big thing we actually contacted the kids
this morning uh cuz they've been in the
backseat now they're all adults um and
listen to say hey what was it d Ry what
it look like for you guys to see it you
know kind of growing up and they're 30
28 and going to be almost 26 and uh they
all called us individually which was
sweet but they all said you guys always
went to the envelope system to grab
their cash out and we remember you
grabbing get $40 we're going to Broncos
which was the Friday night Mexican seat
there we go so it really was you know
the cash cash hurt or cash is freeing
and um and it was kind of funny on the
way over here we came across the
mountain we stopped at Cracker bro we
had a gift card and we paid for our
dinner to the um the gift card and we
shopping a little bit we went back up to
buy something and we saw everybody in a
panic so it kind of tied into the story
is that their system went down for
credit cards and they were like what are
we going to do what are we going to do
no one has any real money these hostages
in the you know in the restaurant uh we
were like we have cash for what we're
going to pay for the blouse and they
were like oh okay and then it was just I
was like oh this is a perfect story to
ties into the journey here so anyways
funny super blessed very cool good job
you guys I'm so proud of Youk you well
done very well done I love it thank you
for your help who know that 20 years ago
me getting in an argument with Oprah
would result in this there you go there
you go well one of the things my son
said that I I want to encourage you with
he says uh he's my oldest and he said
Dad um what I really appreciate about
Dave is you he makes it practical makes
it easy uh he goes but he always aligns
it with truth when he says if you give
the first 10% to the Lord he the way he
honors it and so it's really cool to see
the children mimic it now not only
through their faith Journey but even
through the disciplines you know and um
there's there's nothing better than that
just to hand that off cuz we didn't get
anything handed off to us we we started
with $82 uh we got married wow making
$15 combined income and so it was it's
been a mustard seed of Faith from the
beginning so anyhow that's interesting
you know whenever people come on the
show and they've paid their house off
I'm just shook by that cuz you know
culture says 30-year mortgage you know
keep it for your whole life keep
borrowing against it you may never pay
it off you paid off yours in six years
once you put your mind to it like talk
to that person who's thinks that that's
impossible well with faith nothing's
impossible and that's really was it was
for us it was every month just seeing
God be faithful and we were faithful
back in every Arena and the word says
he's able to do abundant beyond what you
can ask or think and so he knew we were
asking for it and think about it and
he's been faithful and he getss the
glory for it so we're super thankful I
love it well done very well done you
guys fabulous fun stuff you guys are
just beaming it's great we've got the
live and give box for you it's got the
baby steps millionaires book in it which
is your next step and uh of course Total
Money Makeover you can give that to
someone as you're ministering and
Financial Peace University membership as
well the the new version not the CDs and
and uh we can get that you can either go
through it or give it away it's all for
you to live and to give that's why we
call it the live and give box love it
way to go you guys Jared and Jennifer
spart andberg South Carolina
255,000 paid off house and
everything not a payment in the world
did it in six years making 130 to 200
count it down let's hear a debt free
Scream 3 2 1
[Applause]
WI
This Is How We Do It ladies and
gentlemen well done well done well done
fabulous man it makes a lot of
difference when you just kind of get
dialed in yep and um you know when you
and I are running around all over
America doing these media appearances
sometimes you don't even know if there's
anybody watching them that is such a
good point Dave and you look at you know
we're looking at a camera in a studio
with a bunch of bright lights and pretty
people yeah we don't know pretty because
all these people are pretty they're
ridiculous that we're on the air with
and uh you know they're just crazy and
and you know of course we knew some back
in 2005 people watched Oprah we knew we
were going to have a big audience that
day uh but then I did get in an argument
with her and so I didn't didn't have the
desired publicity lift that the Oprah
appearance was hoping to have uh but she
was wrong so but I'm like 18 years later
you got somebody who's then I got
somebody sitting here with her house
paid for and God's transformed their
whole life and uh you know unbelievable
you never know you never know where the
seed's going to look like it's very cool
stuff very cool makes you want to keep
working it does that's right let's keep
going I think I will I think we'll go
talk to about 400,000 people tonight on
that live stream come on literally
that's crazy Breaking Free from broke
that's George camel's new book breaking
the cycle is the thing tonight yeah be
sure you're doing that at ramseys
solutions.com it's a free live stream
700 p.m. Thursday the 11th this is the
Ramsey
[Music]
Show
la
[Music]
thank you for joining us America we're
glad you're here I'm Dave Ramsey your
host Jade washaw Ramsey personality is
my co-host she is the author of our
Ramsey
press quick read money's not a math
problem be sure you check it out on our
website at Ramsey solutions.com Mitch is
with us in Dayton Ohio hi Mitch welcome
to the Ramsey Show hey thanks for taking
my call sure what's up a uh actually
looking for some advice um my my wife
and I started a business a service
business about 15 years ago and we'
built that up to uh about a couple
million dollars a year just under and uh
starting to get some offers on that but
obviously I I we do a little bit of
investing in real estate now but just
wanted your opinion whether I should
keep it it's got a good cash flow or if
I should sell that and go buy more real
estate uh there's not a wrong answer to
that if you can get a good price and you
want to get out of it and move to the
next chapter in your life that's not a
bad thing if you want to keep it and run
it for the cash flow and use the cash
flow to buy real estate that's not a bad
thing there's not you know sometimes
when I'm looking at these things I I I
dial back and say uh 20 years from
today which of these do I
want you want to be running this in 20
years probably not okay you want do you
want to be running it in 10 years do you
want to be running it in 10 years no
okay no probably not okay I think you've
answered your question haven't you is
there well and thank you is there uh
anything else you would invest in
besides uh real
estate because I don't have a
401k nothing like that but okay how old
are
you uh 38 okay and how much will you get
for the business or somebody made you an
offer on it um about 2.5 million
excellent way to go well all of my
personal Investments uh are MIT are in
Mutual Funds growth stock mutual funds
that I do through a Ramsey smart Vestor
Pro and they sit down I talk through it
with them we discuss it they teach me
what that particular fund is doing and
why I might do it and then I choose it
or don't choose it based on what I learn
about it uh and then I buy real estate
and I pay cash for all my real estate
and I've been buying real estate for
gosh 25 or 30 years I guess I've got
several hundred million dollars worth I
love it I love real estate but not
everybody loves real estate cuz it's a
it's a hassle I mean you got to screw
with it it's not people who say real
estate is passive income I've never
owned real estate there's nothing
passive about it Mitch do you already
own a couple of pieces or would this be
your first go at
it uh no we actually have um 13 Doors
right now so we make about 9,500 a month
off of that but they're completely debt
free we don't owe anything on them wow
great that's perfect if you get a$2 and
half million you get a two and a half
million doll check and you want to buy
some real estate with it I would do that
I would also have some in mutual funds
go make sure you're fully funding Roth
IRAs and uh if you can uh look at a
what's called a simple IRA which is for
a small business owner and I guess the
third option for you um you have proven
to be a successful
entrepreneur you might consider at 38
years old what you want to do next it
might be real estate full-time buying
real estate but you might also say real
estate's kind of my side thing and I
want to open a business doing X Y or Z I
don't care if it's an ice cream store or
beauty parlor it doesn't matter to me
what do you want to do and you might run
it for a while cuz you obviously have a
flare an ability to do that yeah very
good so if he's got 2.5 million if it
were you in the situation that he just
described how much how would you divy
that up how much would you put into real
estate Investments and how much would
you put into like stock market
Investments uh well I'm a real estate
guy so I would put a lot of it in real
estate and I would put some of it into
starting a new business if it was me and
then I I you know I put 10 20% of it in
mutual funds but the rest of it I would
go to real estate and to um to you know
starting something up yeah yeah cuz you
need something else to do using it for
some seed Capital yeah 38 years old you
got a lot of you got a lot of runway in
front of you you got a lot of stuff you
can do that's great and so um and again
you've proven that you can operate
something and not not some people can
start things and not operate them some
people can operate them and not start
them yes but he's proven he did both
yeah great great skill set that's that's
a thing that you know not everybody's
got so uh a lot of people dream of
having their own business so you know
you could go that direction um in
addition to that uh I I would consider
that strongly if I were you so good
question good question Devon is in
Milwaukee hi Devon welcome to the ramsy
show hi Dave um thanks for taking my
call
sure um so I'm a college student and I
got a year left and quit my main job so
I could focus on school because it was
taking
a lot of time and now I've got 1,600 in
credit card dead and 8,000 in a private
loan and I was wondering if I should
like worry about that right now and get
it squared away as soon as possible or
wait until I'm making the salary that I
want it's a private student
loan yes you know if it were me you've
got one year left of school I'd probably
Focus mostly on getting out of school
and getting you know making sure you're
making good grades get out of school are
you working at all or you're just not
working
full-time yeah no I am I'm working just
not full-time anymore and where are you
living on campus or you have an
apartment I have an apartment on yeah I
have an apartment I mean do you have
extra I mean if you have extra margin
and you can you know throw it extra on
there I'm not mad at that but I'd really
just be focused on making minimum
minimum payments until I graduated yeah
I want you to have uh I want you to do a
budget on what it takes to complete
school and I will put that in an account
plus
$10,000 when when you've got that then
start paying down your
debt if you get that much before you
graduate then start paying down your
debt but your job one is graduate with
no more
debt yep that's job one and that's a big
job so as you found out so you know I I
think that's very very what are you
goingon to what's your degree what are
you studying I'm a double majoring in
Psychology and computer science what are
you going to
do I want to develop artificial
intelligence but for the time being
software engineering okay excellent so
you're going to be qualified to write
code and do software engineering yes sir
great you in a four-year degree or you
going to code School fouryear degree for
both to get both degrees how much is it
gonna how much is this next year going
to cost
you um
probably 15,000 just to live the tuition
is taking care of and what's your part
time what's your part-time job
I am a lacrosse Co High School lacrosse
coach and um I was a tutor I might do
that again and I do landscaping in the
summer okay wait stop do you not know
how to do code
now no I do why in the world aren't you
doing code well I'm at well I I also do
forw right now for money freelance Cod
writing way better than lacrosse coach
freelance code writing way better than
Landscaping
there's a it's tough though because it's
during the day no it's not it's contract
work you can do it whenever you want to
do
it that's fair dude you really need to
get into that market you can make you
can make some serious money between now
and the time you graduate and it's
building up your experience for when you
go for the the big J talking about
planting bushes when you can write code
mhm seriously go do that right now man
start right now put your get get a hold
of some of your buddies that are doing
this and get your hat name in the Hat on
some freelance contracts and you you can
work a ton of hours writing code in the
in the freaking evenings mornings
weekends whatever else around your class
schedule and still graduate without any
trouble and you're going to make enough
to blow this debt out and cover your
expenses and finish school and have some
money you you got a great career you
picked out now go stand right Square in
the middle of it and I really don't give
a rip about your psych your psychology
double major in terms of the income
you're going to
it's got nothing to do with your income
your income is square in the middle of
code software engineering you can be
making two bills man in no time if you
get out there and learn how to build
platforms and do this that geez come on
get out there and be a Dev three step
yourself up if you got a four-year
degree into that good Lord son go make
you some money yeah please starting
right now Ready set go getting the
degree in the piece of paper doesn't
signify the starting point right now go
get them get them him now was I unclear
say it again get
him this is the ramsy
[Music]
show
[Applause]
[Music]
la
live from the headquarters of ramsy
solutions it's the Ramsey show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships Jade washaw Ramsey
personality author of the quick read on
the Ramsey press called money's not a
math problem she's my co-host today open
phones at 8 25
5225 Allan is in New York City hey Allan
how are you hi great thank you for
having me on the show thank you how can
we help my wife and I are starting to
set up our estate plan Beyond just the
basic will we are still a ways away from
normal retirement age and in the middle
of an entrepreneurial career we are on a
good trajectory and expect that things
could be doing reasonably well by the
time our state plan is in effect and
want to set things up properly from the
beginning MH good you've mentioned a
number of things you did at Master
Series and on the show in terms of
setting expectations and communicating
with your children and other
beneficiaries as well as setting up
protections to ensure you're not causing
harm to them in terms of funding bad or
dangerous behaviors for a couple who is
just starting this process can you walk
us through how you did this what
instruments you used what your uh how
you implemented them how to find the
right attorney what question should we
asking all while following biblical
principles and stewarding what we have
well in doing
so yeah if I had six
hours um okay let's give it a shot here
um there's a lot going on this none of
this will turn out well if the kids
don't that's the start that's the start
and so there's not a legal instrument
that will do anything except keep money
from them in the event that they that
that makes them okay there's not a legal
instrument that makes somebody that's
not okay become okay all you can do is
keep money from them that's all you can
do which is a good thing because you
don't want to fund a heroin addict
because if you fund a heroin addict you
in a sense are going to kill them
because they're going to OD so and
that's not what you do for people you
love and so uh we don't want to fund
misbehavior we want to uh we want want
to do that so that that it starts with
that and it starts with communicating
that early and often to the kids as
they're growing up and even as they're
adult children later on you can have
this conversation periodically uh it's
just okay this is what it looks like
this is what it looks like this is what
it looks like and um the then the actual
thing we had to search for attorneys
that uh you mentioned biblical
principles so I'm looking for an
attorney as a as a person of faith that
is also a person of Faith because they
don't look at me like I've lost my dad
gum mind when I put out some of these
ideas okay I don't need somebody judging
all my stuff I just need somebody help
me figure out the legal way to implement
my ideas and so that's what I'm looking
for in an attorney and um I did go
through a couple of them uh to get to
that um one of them was a strong person
of faith and wasn't a very good
attorney um and one of them was a great
attorney and wasn't a good person of
Faith so you know that's how you know
you got to you got to work that through
and sometimes they don't look like what
they are and you get to sit down with
them so anyway once we sat down um we
had a different scenario for our
children when they were minors than when
they've become adults and so
today the way our estate is in place and
has been for about a decade was when the
last kid came out of college Daniel we
sat down with all of them and their
spouses and said okay as for me in my
house we serve the Lord and so this this
money that is ramsy these assets that
are ramsy are owned by God and I'm the
manager so what I'm getting ready to
unpack for you is going to blow your
mind a little bit but you did not hit
the lottery instead you're optioning
opting into taking on a tremendous
responsibility because managing assets
for anybody including God is a
responsibility and so there's a lot of
it here and there's a lot to manage so
your kids they didn't know they did not
know our Network until after were they
were they totally blown away like did
they have any inkling no they had no
idea wow well they knew we had money but
to them they didn't they didn't know
what they didn't know what that meant
the definition of that so I mean they
knew we could travel they knew we could
buy a car you know but they and they
knew that people knew who their dad was
from authors and speaking and that kind
of stuff but they didn't they never had
added up what Ramsey the company was
making and so anyway we we sat there and
they're like to their to their credit
they were uh a little bit shocked but
they were like okay I get it I'm here to
manage and I said you know and the way
the trust is set up is if you're you
can't manage God's stuff if you're not
walking with God and so if you're not
going to be in a an active relationship
with God you're going to be removed from
the trust automatically and that's the
that's the terms of the trust and then
we go into great detail if someone Falls
away and comes back how can they do that
away and two of them have to make a
decision after I'm Gone the other two
there's three kids so um and you know we
the thing has teeth in it it's got the
ability to manage that because again I
don't and I explain to them again this
money is not for you to sit on the back
of a yacht right and have a servant peel
you a grape well there is a there is
some question around the rest of your
life and not work part of being Godly is
working how do you find Dave um that
level of which to be generous to your
kids without like you said kind of that
entitlement setting in is it different
with each child is it you know as you go
do you sit down and say okay you're each
getting like how do you how do you
navigate that if there's entitlement
then they're they're they got confused
about who owns it MH they think they do
true so then they're out they're not
going to be there so this is what we've
talked about they I mean but they're
growing up I mean Daniel's 8 years old
we bought the first nice car after we've
been broke and we're coming back we
finally got rid of the hoop he got a
decent car and he lays back in the back
seat and goes you know we're doing
pretty good and I said we aren't doing
anything you got nothing I'm doing
pretty good you got nothing buddy and
you know so that that break that
entitlement early and often right I love
that Ain no we here buddy you ain't got
a mouse in your pocket so um you know
we're just walking that through and we
had this actual discussion lots of times
it was almost humorous around the Ramsey
house so but the whole thing is okay
generosity is easy cuz it's easy to give
away other people's money it's easy when
you don't own it true that that's a good
that's good it's easy when you're a
steward so they watched generosity and
they understood it's easy because we
don't own this this is just God's and
God said take care of that single mom
over there that that couple over there
who lost their job and they're getting
ready to lose their house God said take
care of them so we're taking care of
them by the way and by the way you're
not supposed to talk about it it's just
us doing this right you keep it down the
down low and we just taught it taught it
taught it taught it taught it all the
way Growing Up So then when they get
this Revelation thing at the you know
that one meeting it's like okay this is
just a further this is
responsibility it's not woohoo I'm gonna
be on a reality show because I'm an
idiot and I have money and you know and
I'm on the back of a boat and I don't
work yeah you know and how how Bizarro a
life can I live as a trust fund
you know and you know that's it's not an
option if you're a ramsy cuz you're
you're out you got no money you won't
have the money to do it so you're going
to be on the street you know that that's
the thing cuz I mean it's because that
that's not a fulfilling life Hedonism
like that is what we call it that's
right okay Hedonism has absolutely zero
fulfillment people that do that crap are
not happy people that's right the
happiest people on the planet are
generous people and people that serve
and if you're not going to do that
you're not going to be happy and I'm not
going to put you in a position where
you're not happy after I'm gone and
that's how the whole thing's written up
that's great this is the Ramsey
Show
[Music]
[Applause]
next Tuesday January the
16th will be launch day for George
camel's brand new book Breaking Free
from broke the Ultimate Guide to more
money with less stress this is an
Incredible Book extremely well
researched and George becomes the
ultimate snark consumer Advocate uh full
of snark did I mention he's full of
snark and um it's incredible the he goes
into great detail on a lot of the
consumer products that are out there all
over the place that you guys just bump
into every day and he explains to you
the behind the scenes look about how bad
they're sticking it to you it's pretty
incredible so this book includes a
special offer to receive three months of
the premium version of every dollar for
free if you buy the book before Tuesday
between now and Tuesday before January
15th it's a $20 book and we're going to
throw in a $100 of free bonus items
because the pre-orders really help the
marketing plan it'll help George it'll
help us thank you for doing that and he
takes all this stuff straight on like
credit card schemes investing traps
mortgage mythology the stuff you should
have been taught and the stuff they've
dressed it up with a new digital set of
clothes on and stuck it in front of you
again it's age-old scams but they're
back and he goes through every bit of it
and shows you exactly how to get your
money together breaking free from broke
order it right now at ramsy
solutions.com store and you can get $100
worth of free bonus items including the
audio book The ebook an online private
event a Q&A with George and instant
access to George's newest talk show me
the money wow he will be on with Jade
and I tonight along with Rachel Cruz and
Dr John deloney on Thurs Thursday night
the 11th and I will be on at 7:00 and
you can go to ramseys solutions.com
breakingfree and get that uh free sign
up for that it's a live stream we're
doing tonight it's going to take us a
little over an hour so settle in and pop
some popcorn and we're going to walk you
through how to break the cycle you need
to break the cycle and that's what
actually what it is it's ramsy
solutions.com breakthe cycle but the uh
uh you know it's all completely free
there's about
400,000 folks registered already it's
the largest live stream we've ever done
so thank you guys for your participation
and uh we look forward to seeing you
there those of you listening live at
this second will'll be there in a few
hours on the on the old YouTube uh
putting it out there for your stream and
you can also pick it up of course on our
website if you register and we'll show
you how to do all that just make it easy
for you it's completely free so um
really excited about this material Jade
the talk you put together is pretty
incredible well thank you you know I
didn't know I was going to do that talk
and one of our speech writers said well
Dave Dave said this is the moment where
you're supposed to preach and so I said
well I guess I need to write I guess I
need to write a little of a sermon there
for that yeah so you set it up yeah well
you're you you have the ability to do
that on stage and you're fabulous so I'm
looking forward to watching that tonight
as well as Rachel and you talking about
every dollar and Dr deloney talking
about anxiety and George talking about
some of the traps and uh it's it's
really good it's some good material
tonight of course I'll be in there
mixing up and my job is just generally
to spread hate and dissension and it's a
spiritual gift so I'll be in there
stirring up everybody and keeping you
moving and uh have some fun with it as
well so looking forward to it tonight
guys Hannah is with us in Los Vegas uh
hey Hannah welcome to the ramsy show
what's
up hi
um wow it's weird to actually be talking
to
you um so my question is I am a
veterinarian um and I also have a
15-month-old daughter at home and I'm
sure you hear this all the time but
after I had my daughter my priorities
kind of shifted a little bit good um
like you're a good
mom yeah yeah so I I'm currently working
parttime which I'm I'm really enjoying
and I I just really feel I'm a Christian
and I I just really feel called to be
exactly like you said a good mom and
especially as she starts getting older I
just want to make sure that I'm more a
part of her life than culture is um I
guess my question is I I don't want to
be shooting ourselves in the foot down
the line as far as Retirement and like
college savings and things like that go
and I just want to know your perspective
as you know a parent a Christian and
obviously a financial expert how much's
your husband make what's he
do um so he is a an Air Force so he
makes to be honest his pay always
confuses me because it's split up on all
these weird little chunks but I think
his like take-home pay is like 50,000 or
something like that okay all right Co
what was your take-home pay like when
you work full-time as a vet what do you
bring
home yeah so it's kind of complicated
because I'm doing relief work right now
so I'm getting paid basically per shift
as a 1099 employee um so I would say
working three days a week I'm I'm going
to average around 70 or 75 MH okay but
be before how long have you been doing
that are you guys used to that
70 um so I just started doing this we
just moved here uh in August and I just
started doing this in M okay so let me
go back to your original philosophical
question um you can work
full-time be a wonderful mom and raise a
daughter and be a Christian you can stay
at home
fulltime and be a wonderful mom and
raise a daughter and be a Christian
none of those
are U mutually exclusive to having a
good spiritual walk and being a great
mom uh working full-time creates a
different challenges and different ways
you go at it or working part-time does
uh you're not irresponsible about the
future with college funds and retirement
and all that um you know none of that so
none of that guilt type crap I would use
to make this decision I wouldn't let
that be your motivator okay uh in other
words I wouldn't go fulltime at home
because I thought that's the only people
who are spiritual that's just cuz that's
just wrong or if that's the only way you
think you can like raise a good kid yeah
that's that's also wrong lots of great
kids are raised by professional ladies
who work full-time thank goodness so um
it happens it happens all the time it
happens all the time now you're in a
season with a
baby that's a whole lot more uh high
maintenance mhm M then when they're
eight when they're eight they won't even
know you're gone that's a good during
the day you know that kind of thing
right so you you might say okay we're
going to for this season do this leaving
my all my licenses intact and active and
keeping all my continuing ed or whatever
else has to be done up because you've
worked too hard to get
here yeah becoming a vet is more
difficult than becoming an MD because
you have to learn more than one body
type yeah I mean the MD only has to
learn the homo sapien you got to learn a
bunch of them that's true and what you
said Dave is so true um with our with
our kids I mean we've got a three and a
5-year-old and I wanted to be home when
they were super little and then when
they got older it felt right for me to
go off and be able to do more things and
once they go to kindergarten there's so
much more time that frees up so what
Dave is saying about like keeping your
certifications up to date and really
staying active there's something to that
right now you've got one
and you might find that there is still
some form of parttime work that you can
do um or you might find that you just
love staying home and that that gives
you Joy and you might end up doing that
until they're 18 who knows but I would
do something just for you just for you I
really do I mean I do enjoy working I
mean I don't I don't care if it's one
day I don't care if it's a half day a
week but I would do I would do something
because I think it'll help sanity that's
just that's Justa that's just Papa Dave
talking I think you can go in there and
do processes that and and work systems
that you're that are automatic versus
the hecticness of a of a newborn so uh I
think that's just a good thing for fun
and it keeps you plugged in here's the
thing the only thing I would urge you to
do and again I would avoid any personal
condemnation or or accepting anyone
outside's opinion that's that's
condemning so and I'm not going to be
one of those voices the only thing I
would just tell you to do is I think you
will regret if you don't Steward all of
the hard work to become a vet that
you've used so far by keeping all of
that intact yeah and keeping those doors
open absolutely because you work too
hard to just drop this I agree and I
think that I think you'll regret that
later and I do want them to run some
numbers because going like losing
$70,000 of income is a big deal so do
run those numbers sit down with your
husband make sure you know exactly how
much he makes yeah Sharon was fulltime
mom and now is a full-time Mimi so uh
you know basically all but s years of
our 42 years of marriage so before kids
came so there you go I mean there we
[Music]
go
Jade washaw Ramsey personality she's my
co-host today in the lobby of ramsy
Solutions on the debt free stage Ben and
Stephanie are with us hey guys how are
you great Dave how are you better than
we deserve where do you guys live
Colorado Springs color
oh that's cool that's a great town well
good to have you in Nashville welcome
welcome how much debt have you paid off
$242,000 Dave how long did this take 24
months whoa kicking it wow your range of
income during that time we started the
journey around 15,000 and ended around
$280,000 let's go yeah what do you'all
do for a living I'm a nurse and I'm a
cyber security engineer okay so how in
the world you go from 115 to 280 in 24
months uh as a ly things Dave um one
when we started the journey Stephanie
wasn't working we just had our okay son
Nate and then also uh finished my
Master's Degree and got a couple cyber
security Sears along the way jump jobs
and all those things kind of together
yeah boom boom boom boom yours went
yours went straight up the ladder and
then she took on and go yes sir in
that's big that's a big jump so what
kind of debt was the 242 it was our
house look at the weirdos super weird
Dave super how old are you young weirdos
33 years old with a paid for stinking
House in Colorado
Springs oh my God what's this house
worth about 480 oh my gosh so how much
have you got in your nest eggs uh we
have around 400,000 or so and you know
we did our net worth thing around 920 is
is where oh you're right there I bet
such millionaires at 33 years old wow oh
my gosh that is just middle finger to
society that's all
that just yeah that's hey for all the
all of you that think Millennials are
failures I'm talking to two of them that
aren't yeah way to go you guys well
especially man beautiful beautiful
beautiful beautiful well done well done
all right so tell us the story what
happened 24 months ago cuz everything
went nuts yes so Dave our journey
actually started about four years ago um
my dad gifted us The Total Money
Makeover as a Christmas gift MH and the
first thing he said was like hey you
don't have to read this book but I wish
I would have known about Dave and his
plan when I was your age and my dad he's
an accountant he's always been really
good with money and I figured if I
should read if he says I should read a a
book about Finance I probably should wow
yeah so good for you A lot of people a
lot of people that's an excuse to toss
it in the tray pretty much pretty much
yeah so um but you know we just decided
to read it it was a quick easy read and
we were immediately on board um
initially the plant um
you know we had always been Consumer
Debt free with the exception of a small
credit card um but then uh we just
quickly got on board um we knew um at
the time Ben was active duty in the
Marine Corps ah okay and we were renting
and we knew the ultimate goal was to buy
a house and so we just kind of
stockpiled cash for the next kind of two
years or so um you know 2019 happened
then 2021 we were all in the same boat
with the co pandemic we were stationed
in California we really couldn't go
anywhere or do anything except go to
work thankfully we had um covid proof
jobs with me being a nurse and him being
the in active duty so we just quickly
kind of got to work and we couldn't
really spend any money or travel so we
just stockpiled cash for that down
payment and then 2021 rolls around which
is what we call our year of chaos cuz we
just did multiple life altering events
within I'd say like 90 days uh Ben got
out of the military after 8 years of
service starting a new job in the
civilian world I'm 8 and a half months
pregnant with our son done we're moving
from California to Colorado oh yeah in
that crazy real estate market in 2021 we
we're first time home buyers oh wow 90
days yep 90 days oh my gosh thankfully
because of our large down payment it set
us apart from a lot of the buyers and we
weren't the highest offer on our house
but it's because we had the largest cash
off or you know cash down payment that
set us apart from the other W you didn't
get caught up on like driving the price
way way way up exactly that's great yeah
good for you guys yeah so you move take
new jobs and have a baby all in one
month oh yeah yeah why not no big deal
you know no big deal do rental we were
in a rental we were in a hotel room for
a week we were in that new house and it
was just me and the strong back and the
super pregnant woman is looking at you
like what have you done uh pretty
much what have you done yeah you you get
in trouble just for breathing wrong at
that
point uh you're not lying
I
know well done you guys well done you
got to be super proud yeah we are man
you got an incredible income thank you
for your service by the way thank you
and uh man you and you you are set
you're going to make you're going to
have so much money be so a be able to be
so generous completely change your
family treat your dad's got to be going
touchdown I love it is this him with you
all right good he came to celebrate with
you very good well he should he should
that's excellent stuff excellent stuff
well done man I'm proud of you guys and
I know they are very very good all right
now I mean you kind of had this um
almost forced on you because you're
coming out of the military uh you don't
get to choose that you don't get you and
you happen to choose well maybe sort of
to have a baby around that exact same
time you don't choose pandemics you do
choose to move cities so I mean you guys
stacked all this up um and and then you
in the middle of that you go okay this
is game this is game on this is where we
prove this stuff out yeah so tell people
what the what kept you together through
all that not together with each other
but I'm saying how you your brains just
didn't explode you go crazy and have
$7,000 in $70,000 in credit card debt
and a mortgage where you can't breathe
instead of being debt-free you went the
other way extreme yeah I mean I'll go
and jump in I mean we've we've done a
lot of hard things together you know uh
I think like the hardest thing we did
was uh we did a Dey right and and
workups for deployment a lot of times
you know it's like a year year and a
half and you're gone eight months of
that time so it's it's kind of like
you're switching back and forth between
yeah I'm here but I'm not physically
here mentally or whatever and I think
that was probably the hardest thing that
we ever had to do as a couple and uh
that 8mon 9month deployment um was was
hard uh but it it really like brought us
together and this money thing is another
way if it's just a share language you
know like CU we can set our goals
together CU that's where our money goes
wow and so like all those things kind of
combined like I really feel like we can
do anything together you're superheroes
nothing gets between you like nothing
can get between you nothing can overcome
you guys at this point because you've
just proven you can overcome anything
really thank you wow thank you good
stuff all right what do you tell people
the key to getting out of debt is and
it's not move come out of the military
and have a baby in one month that is not
the key that if you don't have to start
yeah um so I just say like nothing is
deserved everything is 100% earned um
just throughout the whole journey like
nothing I thought he was the
marine she's hard
woman yeah um yeah it's just you know
nothing is deserved it's 100% or like
you have to live with that mentality not
in just aspects of your financial life
but your personal life your professional
life um it's it's just the way to go
forward and and grind through it you
know it's it's a short amount of
sacrifice to set you up for the rest of
your life that's right you did it you
did it I mean you really really this is
amazing you poured it on and really what
happened was your incomes went through
the stratosphere and you just you just
kept your lifestyle and your emotions
down and used all that extra money and
paid off the house yes yes sir that's
the way you all did it I mean cuz 24
months 242,000 that's 10,000 bucks a
month yeah I mean it's $120,000 a year
right that's strong yeah we had this
little kind of this little debt C I
guess a little debt tracker kind of
almost made it into a game um with these
little balloons attached kind of like
from the movie Up and then at the end of
at the end of every month we would have
whatever was left over that we had in
our budget we would get to color in
balloons so we were kind of like okay
how many balloons did we get to color in
this month and so it was kind of really
fun to kind of Stack Up you know and
kind of see the progress along the way
all right bring the kiddo in introduce
him what's his name and age this is Nate
this he's two years old he's a wild man
all right wild man here we go hey we've
got the baby steps millionaires book
you're almost there you really are there
uh The Total Money Makeover book and
financial peace univers City to say
thanks to coming to Nashville your mom
and dad are over there sitting proud
they should be we're proud of you you
guys are an incredible couple you you
got your Heroes way to go so so well
done
$242,000 paid off in 24 months making
115 to 280 Ben Stephanie and Nate from
Colorado Springs house and everything
almost baby steps millionaires by age 33
count it down let's hear a debt free
Scream 3 2 1 we're de
fre
[Music]
yeah yeah baby this is how it's done
boys and girls man they are got it going
wow this is the ramsy show
[Music]
ow
our scripture the day Ephesians 210 for
we are God's handiwork created in Christ
Jesus to do good
works which God prepared in advance for
us to
[Music]
do John Maxwell said God uses people who
fail because there aren't any other kind
around listen I have not heard John's
quote on that I like that
John yeah he and I've been friends a
long time I've never heard that quote
that's a great one there aren't any
others around it's really his only
option Matthew is in Chicago hey Matthew
how are you hi Dave how's it going I
appreciate you taking this call today
sure what's
up so I recently graduated college I'm
22 and I got married uh last summer
congratulations over what thank you
thank you and I find myself overwhelmed
with student loan debt um I racked up in
about three years at a private college I
racked up
$198,000 in student loan debt uh with an
average interest rate of 9 to 14% good
luck Lord sheesh yes what
else um and I have about 5,000 in credit
card debt um my wife um we went to
college together and she graduated debt
three so it's good only me with the debt
okay what do you guys
earning uh what was that again sir what
do you ear what do you earn what's your
incomes oh uh monthly income is
approximately
$3500 a month
$3,500 a month okay that's correct and
each you and your wife or yeah that's
combined so are you both working
full-time yes what you get your degree
in for $200,000 it doesn't pay you
minimum wage you're not going to like
this but it was Aviation I'm a pilot
okay why aren't you are you
working um yes I'm working full-time um
and I make $45 to $50 an hour but it's
dependent on three factors du who want
to fly weather and aircraft maintenance
so you're teaching are you yes you're
not flying commercially
or no I have a conditional job contract
offer um signed and hopefully we'll be
starting at the end of this year
starting at 84,000 a year okay um but I
have to work up to my hours to get that
job okay and is there anything else that
you can do to supplement your income in
the meantime while you're working up to
that not much um I could possibly get a
part-time job um that's one thing I've
considered multiple times I'm currently
at my job I'm hours to do she does Army
Contracting she works for the US
government and she makes what she
started at 49 and then she'll go up 59
this summer and then next summer she'll
go up to 69,000 okay that's not 3500 a
month you've Mis added somewhere you so
it sounds like you're making about
40,000 a year going towards 855 in the
fall and she's making about 40 heading
towards 60 in the summer okay so you
guys probably have a household income of
more like 80,000 not 3500 a month which
is 40,000 and maybe you're take-home you
may have you may have too much being
withheld I don't know but basically what
it amounts to is your careers you came
out of the gate with your degrees with a
slow start income wise mhm okay but one
year from the day it sounds like both of
you will be further mature in your
careers incomewise and it sounds like
your incomes are going to be you know
you should be bumping up 150 by the end
of this year
right 60 and 80 is
140 that's the end of the year okay yeah
that's that's ideal yep yeah well that
would be what she's be making 59 in the
summer and you're going to be making 84
in the fall so that that's the way that
adds up so yeah so right now it's tight
um and James what's the name of our uh
refi company why refi why with a like
the letter Y uh like you
why like yours letter y letter Y and
refi you need to look those guys up they
are the best in the business at private
student loan refinance and they probably
can get your rates down yeah cuz 14% is
not ideal yeah you got hammered with
that and that's Aviation school that got
you not standard student loans mhm so um
and then from there you know the formula
is like everybody else you live on less
than you make and tear into it but I
think my my point is Matthew that you're
going to be
um not making a ton of progress between
now and
June from June to January you're going
to make a lot more progress and the
following and and every time thereafter
okay so what I want you both to do is to
work all you can work and if you're on
the ground because of broken aircraft or
weather I want you doing something else
that's right go make some money go
deliver pizzas or door Dash or drive
Uber I don't care what you do go make
some money you need to be working all
the time yeah that's you have made an
unadulterated
$200,000 mess and you have got to focus
on it and attack it with a Z with a with
a like a zealot like you're like you've
joined like I'm crazy that's right you
got to get crazy about it but the good
news is once you guys really get into it
I mean they're going to be average
they're going to be that person who pays
off their debt in around two years two
and a half years and on to the next
thing yeah I mean if it takes you
200,000 bucks if you put 100,000 a year
towards it it's done in two years that's
right um You may not quite make that
depending on how these incomes stack out
and what they when they start flowing
but that would be starting one year from
now and whatever you do from now until
then you'll make progress on so you know
you probably have from today over 2
years worth of work to do maybe
approaching three MH but uh but you'll
be out in that if you lean into it and
don't go buy a bunch of stuff and keep
everything down you know and just just
you know keep your rent down rent the
cheapest possible thing don't go on
vacation don't eat out you have a mess
to clean up and there's no you
know when you're 22 years old you got
the energy go do it that's right go and
don't wait till you're 32 don't keep
this around like it's a freaking pet
yeah get after it Ally is with us in
Minneapolis hi Ally how are
you hi Dave I'm really good how are you
better than I deserve what's
up well so me and my husband we just got
married about three months ago congrats
and when we got married thank you when
we got married we decided we were going
to be um debt free like you teach but
we've kind of hit a little bit of a bump
in our road um we have a car and a Truck
that we just made a really stupid
decision to purchase but the TR has a 30
the truck we bought about two or three
years ago um the car we bought last year
okay so this and after that you decided
to get out of debt so what do you owe on
the truck yes the truck is has a $30,000
loan and what do you owe on the
car 35 okay and what's your household
income about
120 okay all right
well you probably need to sell the truck
or the car one of the two yeah because
you shouldn't have vehicles that total
up to be more than half your annual
income and you
do I agree I agree with you I actually
I'm trying to convince my husband to
sell both and idea really crappy
Vehicles so we can get out of debt
faster and I like that um buy a house
and then have kids but I like that we
are upside down on them well I'd rather
ow 9,000
35,000 and I I agree so we have 7,000
upside down on the car 7,000 on the
truck but so we're thinking would it be
a smart idea to take out a personal loan
to pay those and then buy two cheap cars
drive around okay I would rather you
have $14,000 in debt than $70,000 in
debt okay and that's what I told my
husband he's not 100% on board with it
he really likes his truck yeah he likes
his truck he's got a great truck but
here's the thing you like the Future
Vision that you have which is living in
a home with a couple of babies more than
you like these stupid
cars and so for you the stupid cars are
gone and I think I agree with
you okay then let's just set a super you
know let's set a vision that's past
Friday let cuz here's the thing you can
get another truck you can't get another
life you got go got to go live this life
wide open yeah it makes no sense I just
I'm not a car person so it doesn't hit
me the same but I'm like listen you get
in your car you drive to work you drive
home like no I'm a truck person I
completely get why he likes it but you
guys got to decide what you like more
yeah EXA exactly that's all it is and um
I I like kids and houses better than I
like trucks right and always will that
puts us hour the Ramsey Show in the
books we'll be back with you before you
know it in the meantime remember there's
ultimately only one way to financial
peace and that's to walk daily with the
Prince of Peace Christ
[Music]
Jesus